>>> THE MAN CHARGED WITH FIRST
DEGREE MURDER IN THE STABBINGS
OF UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO STUDENTS
IN NOVEMBER BACK IN COURT WHILE
POLICE CONTINUE TO SEEK ANY NEW
INFORMATION ABOUT BRYAN
KOHBERGER.
GARY TUCHMAN IS IN MOSCOW, IDAHO
THIS MORNING.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, WHAT ARE
YOU LEARNING ABOUT BRYAN
KOHBERGER?
>> Reporter: DON, GOOD MORNING,
BRYAN KOHBERGER REMAINS IN THIS
COUNTY JAIL HERE IN MOSCOW,
IDAHO.
WE SAW HIM IN COURT FOR A STATUS
HEARING.
HE WAIVED RISE RIGHT TO A SPEEDY
ST
TRIAL SO WE WON'T SEE HIM FOR A
PRELIMINARY HEARING UNTIL JUNE.
FOR SOME PEOPLE THIS CASE HAS
BECOME ALL CONSUMING.
POLICE AND PROSECUTORS ARE
REQUIRED TO STAY QUIET ABOUT THE
UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO MURDER CASE.
BUT ON THE INTERNET NO SUCH
PROHIBITION.
>> WE HAVE UNCOVERED WHAT WE
BELIEVE ARE OLD WRITINGS OF
BECOME.
>> MOST OF IT ON TIKTOK,
FACEBOOK AND OTHER PLACES IS
SPECULATION AND HYPOTHESIZING.
>> THE EVENING FOLLOWING THE
MURDERS HIS PHONE WAS PINNED IN
JOHNSON, I DAHO.
>> Reporter: THIS FACEBOOK
GROUP, UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO
MURDERS HAS MORE THAN 225,000
FOLLOWERS AND THIS IS ONE OF
MANY GROUPS DISCUSSING THIS CASE
ONLINE.
PRIOR TO THE ARREST OF BRYAN
KOHBERGER, A USER WHO GOES BY
PAPA ROGER WAS A PROLIFIC
CONTRIBUTOR ON THE SITE WITH
MANY CREEPY AND INSENSITIVE
POSTS AND WHAT TURNED OUT TO BE
INCORRECT SPECULATION.
SUCH AS THE WHITE ELANTRA IS A
RED HERRING.
AND THERE'S A FIXED BLADE LIGHT
LEAVES ME TO BELIEVE THEY FOUND
THE SHEATHE.
THIS IS ONE OF SEVERAL REASONS
MANY ON SOCIAL MEDIA THINK PAPA
RODDER WAS KOHBERGER.
AND THIS PERSON, OKAY, THIS IS
PAPA RODGER STUFF IS WILD, HOW
WOULD ANYONE BESIDES HIM KNOW
THIS.
THERE IS NO INDICATION THAT
FACEBOOK OR THE POLICE BELIEVE
PAPA ROD GER, WHO IS NO LONGER
IN THE GROUP IS BRYAN KOHBERGER.
AND THEN THERE'S THIS PRAYER
VIGIL, WITH MANY PEOPLE
HYPOTHESIZING ONLINE.
>> PEOPLE THINK THE IDAHO
MURDERER ATTENDED HIS VICTIMS'
VIGIL.
>> THIS PERSON COMMENTING BRYAN
KOHBERGER SPOTTED PRAYER VIGIL.
AND THIS PERSON, SURE LOOKS LIKE
THE PSYCHO.
BUT A TV CREW HAS VIDEO OF THE
MAN CLOSE UP, IT'S NOT
KOHBERGER.
AND THEN THERE IS THIS.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
ASKING WHO IS REBECCAO FIELD.
>> A WOMAN CALLS HERSELF ASHLEY
SOLVES MYSTERIES, HAS ACCUSED A
UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO PROFESSOR OF
PARTICIPATING IN THE KILLINGS.
THE TIKTOKER POSTED THIS VIDEO
ABOUT TWO WEEKS BEFORE
KOHBERGER'S ARREST.
>> THEY NEED TO DIG DEEPER INTO
HER PERSONALITY SO WE UNDERSTAND
HER BELIEFS AND WHO SHE IS SO WE
CAN FURTHER UNDERSTAND HER
MOTIVES FOR THE MURDERS.
>> WE REACHED OUT TO GALLARD SHE
DID NOT RESPOND.
BUT THE PROFESSOR HAS RESPONDED,
HER LAWYER FILING A LAWSUIT
AGAINST GALLARD.
SAYING THESE STATEMENTS CREATE
SAFETY ISSUES FOR THE PROFESSOR
AND HER FAMILY.
THE PROCESSER SENT CEASE AND
DESIST LETTERS TO MS. GOLDMAN
SACHS BUT SHE CONTINUES -- TO
MS. GUILLARD.
THE PRELIMINARY HEARING WILL
BEGIN ON JUNE 26th IT COULD LAST
SEVERAL DAYS WE EXPECT
PROSECUTORS TO REVEAL MUCH MORE
EVIDENCE.
LAST WEEK WE LEARNED DNA WAS
FOUND ON A KNIFE SHEATHE IN THE
HOME ON THE BED WHERE THE FOUR
STUDENTS WERE MURDERED.
AUTHORITIES BELIEVE THAT DNA IS
KOHBERGER'S.